On the Jeff Goldblum episode recently
and on the Jack White episode,
we discussed how there were a number
of rejected theme songs
for James Bond movies.
Yes, and this is something
that I guess is one of your
orgasmic pleasures in life
is talking about James Bond movies.
It's something that you know a lot about.
I'm not putting you down.
No, and I didn't even bring this up.
No, and crazily, it came
up with Jeff Goldblum
and then came up again with Jack White,
the idea that Johnny Cash
apparently wanted to write
and sing a Bond theme
and submitted it and it was rejected.
So there's a rich history of
famous musicians submitting
and or being even requested to submit
for Bond songs that have not been used.
And I thought I'd put
it together into a quiz.
Okay.
I will read you the name
and the year of the movie
and four musicians or bands.
And you have to guess which one is the one
that actually had a song.
And then you can hear
these songs online too.
How many of these
happened when I was alive?
One.
Oh, fuck you.
No wait, sorry.
No, I'm sorry, three.
What year were you born?
'82.
Three.
Okay.
But these are not things
that either of you,
no one would know these things.
But he knows, he's like,
oh, that band was like big in that time.
No, I've structured the
answers so that that's, yeah.
Just relax.
I'm thinking of you, Sona.
There's no stakes here, Sona.
Just relax.
There are always stakes.
So I'm curious.
Yeah.
I just wanna be very clear.
'Cause I think to be fair
and the listeners will agree,
you didn't set this up that clearly.
These are actual submissions
that were rejected.
Yes.
Got it.
And I'm doing this for
the show and for you guys.
I don't give a damn
about any of this stuff.
I'm not wearing a t-shirt right now
with a James Bond reference on it.
This is a service.
I don't care.
I don't even like James Bond.
You love James Bond.
Don't you have a podcast about James Bond?
Didn't you, over COVID, build a James Bond
Aston Martin out of Legos?
I thought you were heading
for a joke and I actually did.
[Conan] No.
Yeah, yeah.
But didn't you, you did?
Wait, you did?
I did.
[Conan] Oh yeah, he did.
Well, let's do the quiz.
He also built, he built
Sean Connery out of Legos.
(Sona laughing)
A full size, six-foot-one,
Sean Connery out of Legos.
Easier than you'd think.
Yeah, it was, he made it,
it was over 600,000 Legos.
Oh, but you don't like James Bond?
Don't even know who he is.
(Sona laughing)
All right.
Okay, the first--
Again, just to, sorry
just to ring in, 'cause
he never gets this right.
All we we do is recap.
Is when it's time
One more time,
let me understand, these are
microphones and we're in a--
Excuse me.
When it's time for us to
answer, we say our name
and then we answer.
Yes, that's correct.
'Cause he never does that.
And I just wanna make sure.
And he won't be
acknowledged if he doesn't.
So you have to say your name
and then if you answer
incorrectly, you're locked out.
The other person gets to answer.
Yes.
Let's go.
'Cause this is riveting.
You're so angry.
You're like building it
down just in case I win,
you wanna act like you don't care.
I think this is boring.
I didn't even wanna do this.
Yeah, yeah, you're not a
big, huge James Bond fan.
All right, the year is 2015.
Got it, I remember it very well.
The film is "Spectre."
"Spectre," got it.
Okay.
Now I'm gonna read four
musicians or bands.
Ready?
What are you writing down?
Just, just chill, chum.
Ready?
Paul McCartney.
Ed Sheeran.
Arcade Fire.
Radiohead.
Sona.
Arcade Fire.
I'm sorry, that's incorrect.
Conan?
I'm gonna say it's not Sir Paul
because Sir Paul did "Live and Let Die."
And I can't think.
Keep in mind Shirley Bassey did three.
Yeah, but I know,
but I just don't believe
it was Paul McCartney
because I don't picture anyone
saying to Paul McCartney,
"Thanks, pal, but take a walk."
Well, and I'm not a James Bond fan
but when he submitted "Live and Let Die,"
the producer Harry Saltzman
said, "That sounds great.
Who are we gonna get to sing it?"
Are you guys gonna have
like a longer conversation
before he answers?
Okay, Conan, what's your answer?
Ed Sheeran.
I'm sorry, that's incorrect.
Who was it?
It's Radiohead.
Radiohead submitted.
Oh my god.
Radiohead submitted a song?
And you can hear it online, yeah.
And they said, we're
good, we don't need it.
Yeah.
Wow.
And I think it's better than the
What did they?
Sam Smith.
And I like Sam Smith otherwise, but this
I think I remember it.
Okay, the year is 1981.
This has me thinking about you and I,
we both have a slight musical bent.
Yeah.
Gourley, we should
submit a James Bond song
and try and I'd be happy
to sing it, thank you.
It's rejected.
No, no, no.
Oh yes.
It already got rejected.
But we just need to have the title.
We have to have the title.
Yeah.
We have to have the title
of the, do you know what the
next Bond film's gonna be?
No, no one does.
They don't even have the Bond.
They don't have a title yet?
No, so we can make,
sky's the limit.
They don't even
have the Bond.
No, sky's the limit.
Sky's the limit
is a great title!
There it is!
Oh my God.
♪ Sky's the limit ♪
Already rejected.
No one's heard it.
No one wants to hear more.
♪ Wherever you go ♪
♪ What can't you go beyond ♪
♪ The sky is the limit ♪
Oh, we gotta work on this.
The year is 2025.
2025.
The musicians are Conan
O'Brien and Matt Gourley.
Yep, okay, both of us playing the zither.
The year is 1981.
The movie "For Your Eyes Only."
We're in the Roger Moore era.
Yep.
Okay.
Of course.
The four musicians.
Pete Townshend, Pet Shop Boys,
Kate Bush or Blondie.
Sona.
Yes?
I wanna say Kate Bush.
I'm sorry, that's incorrect.
Yeah, I love this game
where she just blurts out
the wrong thing right away.
I like to take a little time
before I say the wrong thing.
That's how quizzes work.
You don't have a discussion
with whoever's conducting the quiz
and then just, you know, be like, well,
it can't be Paul McCartney.
And he's talking about Shirley Bassey.
Like, what is this?
This isn't fair.
You have to answer.
What?
I hate that.
He just like Crocodile Dundee'd you.
I hate that so much.
Oh, nothing fills me with rage.
Yeah, I don't blame you.
It'll be edited up, so
it will come out faster.
That's the beauty of it.
No, we're gonna let people know.
I'm going to.
I'm going with Blondie.
That's correct.
Yes!
And it's I think better
than the Sheena Easton one.
I love Blondie.
This song's cracking.
What is the song?
It's called "For Your Eyes Only."
♪ For your ♪
Does she do it like Blondie?
♪ Your eyes only, 'cause it is you. ♪
No, it's a little more sultry.
♪ Your eyes only and I'm feeling blue. ♪
It's oh, I love that song.
Which? Okay.
"Heart of Glass."
Yeah, "Heart of Glass."
Yeah, okay.
The year, 1995.
Okay.
The film "GoldenEye."
It's Pierce Brosnan's
first time as James Bond.
Yes, it is.
Okay.
Ace of Base, Depeche Mode, Oasis, or Blur.
Sona.
I am just guessing, all
these are just guesses.
Oasis.
I'm sorry, that's incorrect.
Come on.
I'll go with the correct
answer, which is Depeche Mode.
I'm sorry, no.
Dammit, I wanted to come
in with a lot of authority!
You really, yeah, you really.
But you know what?
If I'm gonna be wrong, I want to go in.
When I used to play
basketball with my brothers,
my favorite thing to do was be way outside
and say "Nothing but net"
and then hurl up a giant brick.
It's my favorite thing to do, you know?
Put it up, it's a three.
And then hurl the shittiest
shot anyone's ever seen
and it would smash a neighbor's window.
I'm gonna throw a curveball at you guys.
No, who was it?
I'm gonna throw a curveball at you.
"GoldenEye," 1995.
Is it Ace of Base or Blur?
I'm gonna.
Ring in.
I'm gonna say, Conan.
Yes.
I just think it's too early for Blur.
It feels too early to me.
That's why, Ace of Base is crazy though.
That's crazy.
Is that your answer?
No, I'm just, I think I'm
gonna have to say Ace of Base.
He wants to see if you're
giving him any reactions.
I'm not giving anything.
No, I'll say Ace of Base.
Okay, so you rang in.
Yeah.
I'll say Ace of Base.
The correct answer is Ace of Base.
And they, you can hear this song
but they changed the title
and called it "The Juvenile"
instead of "The GoldenEye."
You're not allowed if you're an artist
to change the title of
the James Bond movie.
Well, no, no.
No, after it was rejected,
they wanted to put it out as a song.
Oh, I see, I see.
I thought I was thinking
of, you know, someone
like Cher saying, I wanna record the song
for the new James Bond movie.
And they're like, okay, Cher, cool.
And it's is like, yeah, well,
anyway, the title of it is
you know, "A Bullet for
the Brain" and she's like
no, no, that's not the
movie title anymore.
She's Cher, she can do that.
Yeah, now it's all about, you know.
She can do that though, she's Cher.
Whatever.
Was Cher ever rejected?
Not that I know of.
I hope not.
I mean, probably never in life.
Cher should never be rejected.
Never.
Look,
already, this segment has gone on longer
than I would've ever wanted
to talk about James Bond.
Right.
So what we're gonna do
is we're gonna roll this
over into a two part--
You have taken your own personal obsession
and hijacked, used it to
hijack a very popular podcast
and you've taken it down
this cuckoo cul-de-sac
where only you wanna hang.
There's never been a popular podcast
that used the term cuckoo cul-de-sac.
Next summer.
Instead of Chill Chums,
it should be the welcome
to the Cuckoo Cul-de-sac.
I like it.
With Conan and his Kwazies, all with K's.
Write that down.
Well, it's another episode
of welcome to the Kuckoo Kul-de-sac
with Conan and his Kwazies.
All right, we'll see you next episode.
If you dare.